[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france a veinticuatro ayer tuvimos como
también lo transmitimos por aquí este
debate presidencial entre el candidato o
presidente francés emmanuel macrón y
también la candidata de la extrema
derecha marine lepén hoy por supuesto
vamos a analizar como lo titula la
prensa francesa y también internacional
abrimos con un par de portadas
liberación una corresponde a la hoy
jueves 21 de abril y la otra rosa buenos
días de nuevo raúl pues ahora vamos a
hablar de la otra portada que
corresponde ni más ni menos hace 20 años
pero vayamos primero a la portada de hoy
de liberación que tiene este primerísimo
primer plano de marín le pen con el
titular todavía no está al nivel no
todavía no está a la altura acompañado
de los siguientes calificativos
liberación dice que marine lepén fue
inexacta o que incluso se equivocó con
cifras que dio durante este debate y que
macro no fue arrogan y califica
finalmente el debate de confuso pero
vayamos a la otra portada porque bueno
es bien curiosa esta coincidencia
temporal la portada es muy explícita no
más claro el agua un gran no con la cara
de jean marie le pen el padre de mari le
pen aquí lo estamos viendo quien
precisamente hoy hace 20 años el 21 de
abril de 2002 se calificó para la
segunda vuelta presidencial frente a
jacques chirac que buscaba la reelección
como presidente de la republica una
situación un poco parecida a la que
tengo a la que tenemos pues ahora mismo
sin embargo hay que destacar que de cara
a la segunda vuelta chirac obtuvo el 20
y el 82 por ciento de los apoyos y
jean-marie le pen no logró ni el 18 por
ciento no unas cifras que se quedan muy
lejos de las que obtuvo su hija ya quien
tomó el relevo de este partido de
extrema derecha en 2017 y muy lejanas
también de las que se le atribuyen según
la sondeos de intención de voto para
este domingo hacia rossi continuamos
hablando del debate de ayer pero no nos
vamos a fijar en la página de news y
frank son fo quisieron ejercicios de
verificación de las acusaciones que se
lanzaron a ambos candidatos eso es
porque hubo pues como en cualquier
debate pues muchas acusaciones y muchas
veces inexactas o directamente falsas
pero hay algunas que también son
verdaderas empezamos por la acusación
del epen a macrón que le dijo que había
cambiado a mitad de mandato su opinión
respecto a la energía nuclear y es
verdad en 2017 macrón decía que había
que intentar reducir para 2025 en un 25%
la dependencia de francia de la energía
nuclear sin embargo ha acabado pues
anunciando la apertura de nuevas plantas
nucleares por otro lado también marín el
hay macrón dijo que durante su mandato
se había duplicado la reducción de
emisiones de efecto invernadero algo que
la página de fase king de liberación
dice que si es verdad que se han
reducido las emisiones respecto al
quinquenio anterior de françois hollande
pero que no ha sido dos veces más rápido
y que gran parte de esta reducción fue
en 2020 durante el confinamiento
por otro lado macro acusó al pp de que
su partido no apoyó el envío de ayuda a
ucrania en el parlamento europeo que
votó en contra y marie le pen negó este
hecho pero la cuestión es que es verdad
así sucedió en bruselas y ya el que fue
un poco el points lines de la noche de
ayer cuando cuando macrón dijo al pen
que dependía que su partido había pedido
un crédito a un banco ruso le pen dijo
que es verdad que no se escondía de ello
y de hecho esto es bastante vox populi
no pero la frase que ha quedado un poco
grabada es que macrón le dijo que el epp
él cuando habla con rusia no habla con
un dirigente de 'tú a tú' sino que habla
con su banquero bueno si vamos a hablar
ahora precisamente de esa guerra en
ucrania
edad de mariupol como la novedad clave
en este avance de la ofensiva rusa y
como la borda al moscú time y el medio
pro kremlin el cosmos no los calla
pravda y que destaca el quiebre
dependent bueno raúl pues en este caso
lo que encontramos es que tanto la
prensa independiente como la prensa rusa
pro kremlin titulan un poco en la misma
dirección y es que en este caso la
información viene directamente no del
ministerio de defensa ruso del ministro
concretamente del shoigú por lo tanto
pues la información es un poco la
versión oficial en todas partes la
cuestión es que lo que sí hay que
destacar es que los medios pro kremlin
destacan en una hablan de de la
ocupación total de mariupol de la caída
de mariupol como una liberación no
recordemos lo que comentaba en los
informativos y hasta toda la ciudad a
manos rusas excepto a soft al esta
planta siderúrgica donde pues permanecen
tanto civiles como soldados por otro
lado el kiev independent asegura que los
soldados rusos estarían quemando
cadáveres en mariupol para eso de
supuestos crímenes de guerra pero no
queríamos dejar de mencionar raúl el
vídeo del 'new york times' que no sé si
podemos ver a continuación estamos
viéndolos en el que se contrastan las
imágenes de grabadas con un dron el 20
de enero de 2022 con respecto a las del
19 de abril de este mismo año no tres
meses han pasado entre unas imágenes y
las otras de esta planta de asof tal en
las que se ve bueno esta devastación no
por la que ahora que no hace falta
añadir más palabras simplemente puedes
destacar un poco que la situación es un
tanto confusa ahora mismo en esta planta
siderúrgica que ucrania pide la que
rusia les permite les permita la
evacuación de civiles y heridos mientras
que rusia de momento bloquea el asalto
pero no abre tampoco un corredor
humanitario y pide a los ucranianos que
depongan las armas muy bueno rosa así
hemos estado en esta guerra
lamentablemente difícil de verificar
toda la información sobre todas las
declaraciones de la vila do rosa
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la revista de prensa
si pasamos ahora los dos puertos con la
maleza